[Musique]
46 campari résidents pousse un soupir de
soulagement après avoir été rescapé des
flammes dans les montagnes de la sierra
nevada
depuis dimanche près de 250 personnes
qui étaient piégés dans différents
brasier ont été sauvés par hélicoptère
plus d'une vingtaine d' incendies sont
toujours actifs en californie ils sont
répartis sur l'ensemble du territoire du
nord de l'état jusqu'à la frontière
mexicaine au sud pour la première fois
en 33 ans
les flammes ont ravagé plus de 2
millions d'âcres de terrain soit environ
8800 kilomètres carrés une superficie
qui équivaut à 8 fois celle du lac saint
jean où 75 fois le territoire de la
ville de vancouver
mais au delà des records ou des
statistiques ce sont des milliers de
maisons de bâtiments et d'autres
structures qui ont été réduites en
cendres les autorités exhortent les
résidents à évacuer les zones à risque
et interpelle la population afin
d'éviter toute situation qui pourrait
déclencher un incendie à femmes indios
make him back de ces jeunes ne le feu
eldorado qui brûlent à l'est de los
angeles a été déclenchée par un feu
d'artifice c'est une explosion qui s'est
produite lors d'une fête pour révéler le
sexe d'un bébé à naître comme celle ci
date et de 2018 également à l'origine
d'un incendie
et c'est violent feu de broussailles ne
se limite pas qu'à la californie six
états de l'ouest des états unis sont
sous avertissement de danger d'incendié
extrême les américains sont loin d'être
au bout de leurs peines la saison des
feux de forêt s'étire généralement
jusqu'en novembre
ici julie et mon radio canada montréal
[Musique]